reject nation greg and john i want to
say is here today we are going to watch
the bad batch episode a dose i have a
bunch of star wars shirts i never wear
for reasons like this because i am
terrible
at taking care of my shirts you can't
wear the same five shirts i wear in
every video
you could but it's better this way the
variety is appealing i think this is
more distracting on the viewer's eye
when they're trying to watch your
reaction so i feel like it'd be more fun
on my end guys if you haven't seen our
reaction to the first episode go check
that out in the meantime subscribe
clicking the notification bell to check
out our you know what i'm trying to say
uh hit that like button while you're at
it full length watch alongs where you
sync up with a time code over at our
patreon page over there we cover so many
shows if you look at these thumbnails
these are just a handful of them where
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch along
included i want to thank for thom jindal
for editing these reaction highlights
for us buddy
you are being such a good human john i
hope you're ready to inform me you work
a piece
right man ah kanan doom is coming back
i don't think he is in this one not this
one but he'll be back with his new name
[Music]
no opening aeration picking up right
where we left off well this is a first
inspecting every corner of the ship
finally tied her out
we are coming up on salukamai
big theory is that she's force sensitive
might be responsible for what leads to
palpatine that'd be a big reveal
oh yeah this would be like her first
exposure to uh
sunlight i don't think camino gets
sunlight but they do i'm sorry it's more
embarrassing that you don't know how
many suns light
[Music]
i like sand
this gets everywhere how cool
that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
this is where dr robotnik is stuck at
the end of sonic the hedgehog
crossover so this friend of yours what's
he doing all the way out here
hiding
that's what deserters do and you trust a
deserter
why not we're all deserters now
echo just realized that you see his eyes
yeah oh my god no
what are we looking at
a booby trap single trip wire
no that's cute
easy right
what do we have here
more clones who've lost their way
it's been a while huh
i believe he is like lives a farm left
and was in clone wars yeah i'm
remembering that correctly i see a few
new faces
echo and omega
cut and sue
where's crossy it's complicated he's
following orders rex told us about the
clown troopers turning against the jedi
you talked to rex when i passed through
yesterday damn just missed him he was
going on about some behavioral implant
he must mean the inhibitor chip the
camera no one's implanted them in the
clones to modify their behavior you said
the regs were programmed but you never
mentioned the chip how else did you
think it worked
you need to stop assuming there's a ship
outside say yeah jack remember me
you got a lot of uncles
omega
we never see kids around here
come with us
oh you're her dad now
like a christmas tune
yeah let's get us ready for the eventual
holiday special
[Music]
what's the purpose of this
to have fun
here you try huh
you're supposed to catch it
oh
the kaminoans don't create without a
purpose
you all have one so
what's hers
it doesn't matter
she's just a kid
battling draws was easy compared to
raising a child
camino wasn't safe anymore well neither
is salukimo loan troopers have already
started showing up i'm heading into town
to book us a transport off world
we can take you where you need to go
nah y'all wanted men it's too risky i
have to do what's best for them
hunter take care of the child
sensing a theme in star wars universe
troops should be pulling their forces
not securing a post war is over
well it doesn't feel that way
[Music]
they started seizing ships about a week
ago they're tagging them inside that
impound lot
i need to book passage on the next
shuttle out of here those credits won't
do you any good without a chain code new
galactic
ships they're registering people too
nice one
man they've been playing that same game
for a long time for days now it's past
defense we'll get it later check
nah you go get it now
go on an adventure all your own
come inside
where's omega
she was right behind me
[Music]
what cool [ __ ] she gonna do
he'll be arrested when they discover
he's a deserter the next shuttle leaves
in a few hours
codes and no codes
we need to be on it mom
mom it's omega she went out past the
fence
don't worry guys omega's got this
handled
[Music]
let's unlock some powers
[Music]
you're the new crosser
would you like to join the team
dick you think you can afford some chain
codes i only learned of them moments ago
but yes
[Music]
[Music]
i owe you one
children will always find ways of
getting into trouble hunter it's what
they do protecting them is what we do
where's omega
she wanted to stay on the ship when you
leave salukimai i want to make it a go
with you
you two can give us something that then
we can't is that what you really want
it's what she needs it's not gonna
happen uh you can't give up the child no
not until luke gets here now people are
signing up to be given numbers it's
ingenious
where are we gonna find the data for
these chain codes
and the disks already thought of that
they're tagging ships inside their
impound facility
that is our way in you're suggesting we
call the authorities and have them seize
our ship that is exactly what i am
unorthodox methods every good plan
involves getting caught
[Music]
this was the simplest solution getting a
shipping pounding is not my idea of a
solution we'll meet you at the spaceport
with the chaincoats
there's one big problem
omega's on the ship
[Music]
i think it's a good plan tick so much
for simple
what kind of ship is this anyway
that looks like a modified omicron class
a tax shuttle
i know exactly what that is my favorite
class of ship
so far so good
go to the security kiosk scorpion copy
the data and grab the blank disks for me
to program copy like create an
echo
[Music]
it's good
[Music]
love a good sneaking mission
i don't see any discs tech
they'll be locked in a safe compartment
yeah this music's on point
fandom excellent
[Music]
yeah for the cantina
tech we're in the spaceport what is your
status
in progress
the encryption shouldn't be a problem
famous last words
we need those chain codes to get them on
the shuttle or we're going to have to
blast our way out of here i can slip
through security unnoticed and deliver
the discs to you momentarily sound very
confident about them
momentarily
no chance you're getting past all them
undetected we can't get caught with
these chain codes we can't get caught at
all what are you talking about we get
tied up in a blaster where the discs go
and where's omega
she's helping out
this great plan of yours is looking
really lousy about now
the same guy voice all of them i think d
d
bradley
d bradley
the chain codes are in root with omega
by herself you let her go by herself
well
we didn't let her go nobody lets omega
do anything
hey who are you you don't belong here
i'm uh the
maintenance tech i've got a situation to
face
new
and here we go that is not ideal we're
in agreement on that one
i hit the spot
they're waiting for you at the dock
better get going
show me your chain coach citizen sure i
got it right here oh right
in this hat
we're running out of time hunter well
stop walking there yeah just you know go
waste time somewhere else
in this bizarre
i can't risk it
you have to find another way out
i'm here
and i have the train codes hear your
chain codes hey guys i got him all by
myself didn't tell her tell me what oh
[Music]
she's not gonna agree to this the extra
chain code's for you so you can leave
with cut and sue why
did i do something wrong yes you failed
the audition for the bad match
they'll give you the life you deserve i
want to stay with you
you have to go omega it's
for your own good
luke skywalker shows up and just starts
this comes out of a time timeline
doesn't make sense
he's everywhere
[Music]
you're clear
gone through
ready
[Music]
my own way out
[Music]
i oh to that
you're the best wrecker omega's not back
wrecker she's not
[Music]
those blasters aren't even set to stun
you look familiar
carry on you look like a carry-on you
look like my mirror
you look like
everyone i know
impenetrable ship
yeah i have a lot to learn this is where
i want to be i guess i've got a lot to
learn too
this is where you want to be then this
is where you'll stay huh
okay
visa
can't be fugitives of my
well done team
whoa is there something here there's
nothing here there's nothing here
nothing here record in here oh i think
there's something here
[Laughter]
wrecker wrecker
and i'm cross hair
not appearing in this episode
but i mastered the impression i'm a just
in case sometimes i'm a good guy despite
sounding like a villain all the time
all right we got mike's now who he goes
that's right we got mike
wrecker sounds like the one character
voiced by a different actor
i think they're all the same it seems
like so
then that voice that he does for wrecker
must get a lot of use elsewhere because
i know i've heard this voice actor
elsewhere oreo only get and he only gets
one paycheck
one paycheck for all
the characters all the clones yeah the
whole bad batch
and whatever
and what i love too is that it makes it
really easy to cast a replacement for
all the different languages that they
need to dub this in because you just get
one actor for
most of the cast it's a little difficult
to follow the first episode because that
one's like a 70 minute
three episodes yeah it's three episodes
in one yeah this had more of the pacing
of like a traditional clone wars episode
it did dawn on me um like especially
when they were because even though they
fight some clones in the other episode
and this one when they are fighting them
at the end it's like wow this is pretty
gnarly to go from
the clone wars where you really get to
know the clones well there's a good
handful of them but you get the sense
that some of them are are real
characters the clones you trust that are
on the right team and then here even
though like from being acquainted with
the movies and you know originally
they're introduced to stormtroopers and
and whatnot but in the medium of the
animation format and then with this
being the same animation style as clone
wars there is this sort of eerie
like uh unsettling effect by man they're
all bad now it's like it's like it's
like fresh all of a sudden of of like
that
we'll be known as stormtroopers one day
it's fresh oh man you still have that
you still have that effect that the
finale of clone wars leaves you with of
oh man they're all bad
yeah i would imagine i mean you know
there's something so
tangible about that quality that and
they even touch on it this episode with
like how else do you think they did it
with chips but yeah this idea that
everybody that you might have known or
who is of your same cloth has just now
been
reprogrammed with literally just one
decision like is is a very eerie
sinister thing and it carries a lot of
weight beyond just the cool action i
hope it doesn't get
repetitive because it seems like there's
gonna be a lot of
escaping from being shot out by clones
and a lot of omega wandering into
situations that maybe she's a little in
over her head with
yeah because the key to this is keeping
it very character focused you know i
don't know when if we'll ever stray away
from
like how they'll handle the focus of
their episodes moving forward yeah you
go to this planet this character cut cut
yes i i vaguely remember him i believe
rex interacts with him in uh in clone
wars i even named rock rex rex was just
there just there they just just missed
him ah that gives hope that rex might
show up in this series she gets me very
excited i love that rex rix
i think he's in the trailer is he i
think there were people freaking out
no no no no because you know because
that was one where i had to look at the
comments we were like oh you could see
rex right there and then it was like oh
cool you're enlightening me so i think
if that is a correct memory i'm having
that we will see him at some point oh
awesome yeah oh i didn't watch the
latest trailer yeah okay because you
were out of town yeah going back to this
episode and seeing like cut again
there's this strange sense of unity that
is brought upon the clones who are are
defects or mutants or whatever word you
want to apply to them other than rex who
was just successfully able to do ahsoka
get rid of the inhibitor chips effects
right because of that it there is kind
of this cool wandering element to to the
like these nomad warrior travelers in
space yeah who are really just so on
their own and i'm really loving how that
tone is carrying on because they're
they're still having to struggle with
like making decisions along the way like
this is so out of their element in their
comfort zone the bad batch clone force
99 is so used to
just being the guys who carry out
missions you know and they have the
reputation for doing that now it's like
all right let's go interact with uh cut
and see what useful information might be
able to derive from there and then they
find themselves having to help them
along the way too it's like yeah there
are things in here that are reminding me
more directly of the mandalorian
especially the dynamics of hunter and
omega and sort of this like wandering
into another mission you know yeah each
step of the journey of us protecting
this kid and finding out the next place
to go we're also going to meet some side
characters and do a side quest and help
them out you know i guess i'm wondering
what the overall
direction of the show is take
mandalorian i gotta get the child to the
jedi clone wars we gotta win the war and
then yes you have all these different
stories and journeys along the way that
are more important than winning a war
rebels again did the rebels fighting
against the empire here
it's like which is a story like was it
gonna end with these guys are these are
they just gonna be like they're gonna
die by the end of this series what's the
journey of just like it seems like
there's so much of them like figuring
out like the hell's going on like we
know but who haven't yeah but they have
to figure it out i'm not sure what the
direction is is omega is supposed to be
like the big heart and soul of whatever
this pivotal journey is within the star
wars legacy because i like the idea of
fleshing out more of the world exploring
more of the early days of the empire i'm
just curious like what the direction is
that they're i have no idea where the
show's actually headed yeah in terms of
it's like straight line
and then around it with all the other
little plot lines yeah i mean i didn't
get to read it in depth but i saw you
know some think pieces circulating
around about how this could potentially
be like the darkest most grim chapter in
this you know branch of the saga because
you do have it pitted in this spot on
the timeline where like yeah the goal of
this series doesn't seem like it's going
to be vanquishing the empire because
it's going to take a lot more time and
movies to make that happen i wonder yeah
if this might be something that is maybe
more not anthology per se but something
that does have yeah a bit more of that
wandering spirit and then maybe does rub
up against the harsher
aspects of the effect because like it's
the rise of the empire right now so that
has to mean that a lot of sinister
machinations are in store and you know
i'm sure we're going to have the bad
batch club force 99 doing their best in
whatever situation they land themselves
in on this stop to you know hinder those
plans little by little and i imagine too
that probably that'll become part of the
arc of the characters is them you know
really stepping outside of the orders
and you know the hierarchy and coming to
some kind of true direction and morality
that they share among themselves because
i like that point a lot that you know
like yeah they were the guys who were
you know
tasked with carrying out these crazy
missions and they're really good at that
but now they're on their own and they're
sort of just an island unto themselves
and so how do you function how do you
reorganize in a situation like that and
i think that's something that would be
interesting and fun to watch and also
seeing how they continue
what started last week with our last
episode with crosshair and all that
stuff you know well it's like i'm
wondering like with the purpose of a
character like having cut show up in
your second episode this uh clone who's
been able to essentially live off the
grid think for himself and have his own
identity for so many years now and have
a family hunter
is thrusted into this position where
he's essentially becoming the father to
this to everyone to everyone but to
omega omega specifically directly you
know hinting at or possibly getting us
to hope for oh maybe this is the kind of
life
they might be able to live one day you
know like they've been fighters and
warriors defects their whole life maybe
they'll have an opportunity but i'm
trying to wonder i'm just wondering like
what the to make this your second
episode other than just introducing the
whole thing with the
what the hell are those called clone
time stamps uh oh the block the chain
code code yeah i almost i almost said
blockchain yeah so there you go uh with
the chain codes yeah okay yeah it's cool
to to introduce all that and watch the
the rise of this and then you're
watching the the slow development of the
empire taking over and putting up this
veil of we won and here's the way we
restore
balance and order but it's like really
nazi like that's all neat but to me i'm
all about like the character and the
theme so i'm like why this be the second
episode in particular i feel like
they're kind of hinting there it's it's
like it seems like such
this the theme of this seems to be so
much about identity for all these
characters you know omega two even
though she's out on her own and she has
this like wondrous
look
upon the planet being able to put her
hand in dirt and remember her uh you
know wife and kid but now she's a
gladiator
maximus
character picks up dirt just right
but even when things were getting hard
like she reflected on being at where her
comfort zone was the place that she
escaped from the place she fled camino
you know like looking upon it's like
well at the end of the day that's where
she felt safe and protected even though
she knows it's not safe there and it's
not a good place there and there's a lot
of questions like i said this it seems
to be dealing a lot with identity and
where do you belong in this galaxy
in the midst of all this like what is
your purpose which is very star wars
uh
and i love that but yeah i guess in
terms of like a plot i'm like well i
guess they're just
just gonna wander into the situation
we're just gonna check stuff out across
the galaxy like they're wanted but
they're not the most hunted people in
the galaxy but i mean omega's very
desired i think that's the thing is that
um i don't think they realize
any of them realize just how much omega
is very much desired like she's the last
of like the clones and they brought up
again people on camino do not make
clones without a purpose
and someone like her who they might have
mastered the ability to i mean that's a
theory that i've heard at least
circulating on twitter is
that she might be force sensitive and
how that could be like the beginnings of
how palpatine was able to which ties
into mandalorian with the cloning and
all that and like but then like well why
do they want the child then
because i thought that was the whole
point of the child yeah in the
mandalorian was to be able to to do the
metacore and
you know to be able to replicate a
force-sensitive body yeah yeah yeah i
don't know
but i think like that the key is that
the key will come down to omega yeah
cause i'm like they're already like a
unit they're already like a family this
these outsiders so we don't really need
to watch them grow as a family i'm like
well they're
like echo's the newest but i feel like
echo's already like he's he's just a
part of them you know yeah man he's
already been paired off for a side
mission he's fully part of the team yeah
so i i i i'm wondering where i i don't
have a clear sense of that yet not that
it's making me uh dismayed i just would
like to know i would like to know the
end when we start
but you know what i know yeah it's like
what is the overall uh story or goal or
or what's the overall theme or whatever
what's the big situation that this
series seeks to deal with yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's a good episode it's a good
episode and uh i liked a lot of it and
action's just cool action's cool
atmosphere star wars
always fun to be a part of be immersed
in i love having the action the clone
troopers are already morphing into
stormtroopers with how
they suck at fun yeah
it's a bad part of the software in the
actual order 66 program i hope
some [ __ ] like that because damn
somebody goes in and looks at the code
and they're like oh damn you messed up
the calibration on their shooting skills
way off i mean i know they're fighting
the bad batch they're they're fighting
they're fighting the bad match but if
anyone should be able to
at least put up somewhat of a fight with
clone force 99 it should be
a battalion of clones nah but see that's
the thing that's jedi is that the bad
batch because they're also clones they
just know so well what the instincts and
tactics of the other clones will be that
they'll just that good at missing it you
know yeah dodging without even having to
break a sweat all right guys
what do you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least let's do
a
jn valente i hope you're safe across the
galaxy man lay low you need your chain
code if you're gonna get out of where
you are and that's a hard thing to get
but you know what jan i have faith that
if anyone can come up with a crack plan
it is definitely you and if the plan
goes awry that's okay you can simply
just start talking to whoever has caught
you and pretty soon they will probably
be so lost that you could then leave the
situation leaving them to still be
puzzling over what it was you said in
the first place thus giving yourself an
opportunity to save your own life jn i
love you man you have a mystique that i
don't think any of our
other of our patrons have and i
appreciate it it makes you special i
don't know how directly to imagine you
so whenever i imagine you i just imagine
you in some far out distant locale doing
some type of strange but very specific
activity so jn
stay sexy out there stay you keep
wandering send us a message sometime i'm
sure you've forgotten by this point that
you're even a patron but we love you and
uh hope to hear from you soon buddy take
care
[Music]